there is a new chess opening going
around and it's called the alien Gambit
and I had no idea about this opening
until a few days ago I played against it
in a Lee chess rapid game and it's been
popularized by chess streamer and
content creator wity alien he's made a
lot of content beating Grand masters
with it and it is a very dubious
aggressive slightly out of this world
variation against the kro which I I
played the other day from the lock side
so in this video you're going to see how
I tried to deal with it it was a very
stressful game with a pretty remarkable
finish so do let me know your thoughts
about this opening and hope you enjoy
the video okay playing
Black all right let's play Let's Play
The kocon there's a lot of kocon fans I
don't usually play the kocon I forgot to
berserk again
oops uh sorry
schwarma Carol time oo two knights
attack so it feels like I'm playing
against
myself
um oh what's the
line I'm going to go for this takes and
then Knight F6 I think is
uh that's like the main main
line Knight
G5 KN G5 it's a trap if I play
H6 there's lines where sometimes
white will sack and then check
but I don't think it works there cuz
there's no Queen H5 I just move
back I hope I'm not walking into
anything probably walking into something
wow what is
this but I have this
move I can't play Bishop E6 cuz then I
lose back the piece E6
also looks
playable actually really confused but
I'm also kind of scared
like
here
here and then here at Knight G6 Rook
somewhere
feel like this is one of these like Tik
Tock
traps G
don't my dear friends maybe not good but
still
dangerous it's scary like White's
playing so quickly too like barely using
any time but I mean once I play
E6 I have to stop the mate there's also
Queen D4 which is kind kind of
interesting but E6 looks
[Music]
safer pawns defended I'm up a knight for
a pawn here thank you Joe price the
first time
Prime okay this is a good sign so and
now I have time to try and
consolidate white is probably
threatening this and then
take yeah it's like a little bit
uncomfortable
but it should be
manageable looking for candidate moves
cuz if I play B5 I mean there might just
be this and then
take so I might want to over defend the
pawn like Queen
here there's also Knight D5
which oh which just blunder is this move
okay not going to play Knight D5 yeah
Queen D6 looks fine I guess the plan is
to play Knight
D7 I spent a lot of time in the first
few moves okay D3 makes
sense Knight
[Music]
D7 Knight D7 Knight G6 though
H yeah white still has some counterplay
could play G5 here
G5
[Music]
H4 I might have to make some
concession let's go for
G5 HP Rook
G8 white does have some like longer term
compensation my pieces are not the
best not on the best
squares
if I play Knight
[Music]
D7 go for
this could also go for
this but then F5
man idea to play
B5
[Music]
I think I want to play B5
first gives me like one tempo maybe C5
C4 at some
point also maybe A5 as
[Music]
well play Rook
G8 Happy New Year
Steph and a big kind of part of working
through this position is just
identifying what white wants to do and
how to stop
it just trying
to develop
before my king gets too
weak like Bishop E7 probably
[Music]
coming so G5 stops a bishop from coming
to
F4 yeah Bishop
[Music]
E7 still kind of
unsettling
wow
I should not have allowed that CU takes
here that's not good do I have this
move I'm in trouble
here take there
there wait a minute no
I oh no King D Knight
F7
I'll still fight
but oh dear maybe KN no 97 still Queen
H5 I'm thinking about this we have two
and then this and then this and then
this might be my best
chance
so white one back the piece the whole
idea of Rook F6 was again and queen H5
which yeah I should have I don't know if
I could have like prevented though
because my KN was attacked and
undefended King H1 if I take Queen H5
King
d8
so the difference here
is I mean with the queen on D6 there's
this Knight F7 Fork but after this this
Knight F7 I can run and then hopefully
hide and then hopefully not flag and
then hopefully
checkmates so I think white probably
should have played Rook F2
there super tricky game so
far
oh my bishop and Rook are
attacked I could
take take and then here and what's
material I'll I'll be up a Knights
somehow also take this
way taking this way is better
although I taking this way has a m
threat
I'll take this
way okay I think I
can calm
down White's considering this move which
would be
interesting yeah I'm up a knight for
Pawn
again but things are stabilizing Bishop
D2 is a good
move have this
[Music]
move there's still weird compensation
for
white
A5 Bishop
C3 Bishop C3 is the threat
wow Knight D7 I
guess it loses a pawn
but at least it defends the bishop
down a lot of time yeah this game is not
over I guess with
um I have to calculate though Bishop E6
Bishop B7 Bishop A5 and then King here
because I'll be attacking the queen and
the bishop Bishop B4
C5 the problem is Queen
[Music]
F7 I don't think I can
afford maybe
just light
B6 I just got to play quicker
have less than a
minute maybe the king will find safety
here A4 B4
so I'm losing the bishop but basically
forcing the bishop trade if takes takes
The Bishop's
defended
his line takes takes Bishop F2
threatening mate but then Rook
C7 and then likely Knight
G4 can I
take that's insane if I can take I think
I
can the key is yeah this move ensuring
the King has no escape and this is
impossible to stop
stop oh no my
queen I mean there's one spite check
maybe a couple spite
checks but it should be made within like
at least four or five
moves or at most four or five
moves hope I'm not missing
anything Queen
G8
yeah the natural line was to look for
Rook h8 first but then the king would
start running
away yeah and here I mean the only moves
to theay may all lose a
queen I think there's four in
total or that but
okay
okay oh that's a relief to Sur
opponent opponent was probably like in
good shape at some point espec I mean
especially after Rook
F6 walked into some tricky Gambit a lot
of blunders this game from both of us
white was completely
winning when I played Queen D4
check so
H6 so this is probably some opening prep
like has this been played
before
it's been played 50,000 times before I
wonder if there's like a YouTube video
or maybe book that recommends this
objectively it's not good but
maybe like good practical option for
Blitzer Rapid or
bullets oh E6
immediately E6 maybe would have
[Music]
transposed
was I thinking I could still
Castle I think there's a point I thought
I could Castle or my plan was to Castle
Queens side forgetting that my king
moved a couple
times oh what's the difference Knight
E5 so this is the best line for black ah
the King can go to
G8 or it's less exploitable here even
though the Bishop's here guess Knight D5
coming
I'm already worse after Queen
D6 and then I was just
losing yeah Bishop E7 was
careless think you test ignore gifting
five Rook F2 only move to keep the
advantage and the plan was to play
Bishop
C5 ah white has an H4 to defend how come
you always make it look so
easy I don't think I made that game look
easy that game was uh was really really
difficult I mean I should have
lost